Therefore, shik is the biggest sin in
Islam and
that is the
cornerstone of Islam. The first pillar
of Islam. It's mentioned in the Quran in
Kabud chapter number 29 verse number 45.
Recite of what we have revealed to thee
by
inspiration and establish prayers salah
for verily salah prayers restrains you
from shameful and unjust deed. The
second pillar of Islam mentioned in the
last and final revelation Quran is
salah that established salah. It
restrains you from shameful and unjust
deed. There's a talk I've given salah
the programming towards righteousness.
It's a one and a half hour talk which
give details from the Quran and the say
hadith that how does salah programs you
towards righteousness and keeps you on
the straight path. The third pillar of
Islam it is zakat.
Every rich Muslim who has a saving of
more than the nisab level 85 g of gold
he or she should give 2.5% of that
saving every lunar year in charity. It's
called a zakat. If every rich human
being in the world gives zakat, poverty
will be eradicated from this world.
There will not be a single human being
who will die of hunger. And the
categories to whom you can give zakat is
mentioned in surah tba chapter number 9
verse number 60. There are eight
categories. The first is fkara a poor
person who has a saving of more than the
nisab level sorry who has a saving of
less than the nisab level less than 85 g
of gold. Number two is
masakin a needy person. Number three is
a person who collects the zakat you can
give a salary from that. Number four
is those whose hearts are coming towards
Islam. Use zakat money. If you know a
person will accept Islam if you
influence him you can use it. The
category
is those whose hearts are coming to
Islam. Number
five a person who's a debtor. Number
six freeing of slaves. Number seven,
jihadi striving and struggling in the
way of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. And
10th is sabil a wayfairer a traveler.
These are the eight categories mentioned
in the Quran whom you can give zakat.
The fourth pillar of Islam mentioned in
the last and final revelation from Allah
subhana wa t'ala. It is psalm that is
fasting. Every adult
Muslim who is healthy, he should fast in
the month of Salah and who's not
traveling fast in the month of
Ramadan from dawn till sunset. He should
abstain from food, drink and sex from
dawn till the sunset.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah
bakar chapter 2 verse number 183 that
Ramadan was that fasting has been
prescribed to you as it was prescribed
to people who came before you so that
you may learn self-restraint. The main
reason of fasting is to increase your
tawa to increase your god consciousness
to increase your piety. Today the
psychologist they tell us that if you
can control your hunger you can control
almost all your
desires. So we are being trained I call
fasting I call Ramadan as a
annual overhauling like you know if you
allow me to call the human being the
machine it requires servicing. So
Ramadan is one month servicing every
year you know to let the machine come to
the top level we increase our tawa we
increase our god consciousness we
increase our piety and I've given a
separate talk on this Ramadan a date
with Dr. Zak it has got a 64 episodes
all details of how
Ramadan is beneficial for us. And the
fifth pillar of
Islam is Hajj. Every adult Muslim who
has the health and the means to perform
Hajj, there is pilgrimage to the holy
city of Makkah Mina
Arafat in the month of Hajj during the
dates compulsory at least once in his
lifetime. Hajj is the biggest annual
gathering in the world where about 4
million people gather in in Mecca, Mina,
Arafat. 4 million people from different
parts of the world from USA, from
Canada, from UK, from Saudi Arabia, from
India, from Pakistan, from Malaysia,
from Indonesia. The men are dressed up
in two
pieces of unsewn white cloth on the
command of Alama. Here we are. Oh my
lord, here we are. It is the biggest
annual gathering in the world. You
cannot make out the person next to you,
whether he's a king or a popper. All of
them two pieces of unsewn white cloth.
It increases the brotherhood.